so I can start with idea validation and
go all the way to see if my product
works well absolutely there's ways for
user research to help you throughout
that process okay so we talked about
user research but what does a designer
do well if you're an interaction
designer like me you're gonna spend a
lot of time grappling with tasks you're
gonna think about well what are all of
the different tasks that the user is
going to perform inside of this product
and for every given task that you have
you're gonna try to dive in and just try
to figure out like that sequence of an
interactions that the user is going to
have and sometimes you can think about
that like a dialogue you can think about
well if the user does X the system is
going to do Y and then the user is going
to come back and do Z you'll kind of go
through that and you'll start by just
kind of shaping one of those but then
you'll kind of go broader and broader
you'll think about all the other
variants of that same task so what if
the user does you know W instead of Y
and how does this system respond to that
and that'll help you just kind of
understand what some of the constraints
are and what some of the things you need
to account for in the design and then
from there you go kind of bigger and
bigger you think about what the next
task is and you start to kind of chain
those together in interesting ways
you'll start to see things that are kind
of commonalities tasks that are similar
or sometimes even the same to each other
that are kind of good opportunities and
also things that are really unique you
know particular tests that have these
very you know one-off set of
interactions that don't occur elsewhere
so I have to map every interaction well
either you're going to map them all or
the user is going to kind of have to
create their own map so trying to
anticipate as many of those interactions
as you can is going to make it easier
for the user to kind of follow through
on those goals inside your product